[MUSIC PLAYING]
WALLY BRILL: Hi, I'm Wally
Brill from Google's Conversation
Design Team.
Today we're talking
about persona,
the personality of any
conversational interaction.
Now Webster defines persona
as your public image.
It's the face you
show the world.
Think about when an
actor assumes a character
for a role in a film
or on the stage.
Here's an example.
When Leslie Howard and Norma
Shearer played Romeo and Juliet
in the 1930s, it was very
different from the performances
of Leonardo DiCaprio and
Claire Danes in the 1990s.
Yet, it was the
same material, just
interpreted with very
different personas.
Before you write a
line of dialogue,
it's necessary to
define the persona.
The documentation you
create will be a North Star
to keep the writing
consistent and clear.
It also becomes the
description of the character
the voice artist will play.
Everyone has a unique persona.
It's there from the
day you're born.
And it develops and morphs
throughout your lifetime.
It's the who of who you are.
It defines us as individuals
to the outside world
and differentiates
us from one another.
So today, I'm going to show you
how to understand and define
the right persona for
your product and brand.
Now, we live in the future.
Communication channels
are ubiquitous,
so people have high
expectations for what
intelligent assistants
can do and how and where
we can interact with them.
So when we talk
about persona, we're
not just talking about a voice.
We're talking
about communicating
with AI that seamlessly
flows across surfaces,
from the Google Assistant
on your mobile devices,
to your car, your smart
speakers, and your smart home.
So we also have to consider
that persona is expressed
through audio content,
visual content, interaction
design, and even typography.
But for a voice-first medium
like the Google Assistant,
let's focus on just why
a clearly-defined persona
expressed in audio
is so important.
In "Wired For Speech," Clifford
Nass and Scott Brave said,
"When people hear
any voice, they
automatically and unconsciously
assign a personality to it."
Within less than two seconds,
the listener automatically
creates a mental image of
who they're listening to.
They identify attributes
like age, gender, education,
where the speaker's
from, and register,
or their role in
relation to the listener.
Did you ever notice how people
refer to the Google Assistant
as "she," "he," or
"they," rather than "it"?
She told me a joke.
I'll ask him for the weather.
That's because we can't
help creating a character
from those attributes.
We go on to make
assumptions about traits,
like intelligence,
trustworthiness,
and likability.
You start to see how important
the perception of the persona
can be.
And now, more than ever, the
experience of the persona
is the brand.
They'll be inextricably
linked the mind of the user.
And remember, each
interaction is
a brand impression,
just like a billboard,
or an ad, or the website.
That's why leaving the persona
to chance just isn't an option.
If you don't design
your persona,
the user's imagination will.
So how do we go about it?
How do we create the
perfect representative
for the task or brand?
To answer that question
and show you the steps,
I thought I'd tell you
a tale of two airlines.
First, Important
Airlines-- they're
something like a
national carrier.
They're a bit traditional
and no-nonsense.
Their strapline,
"We're important,
and we will get you there,"
shows their practical approach.
On the other hand,
Millennial Airlines
is clearly more fun and upbeat.
Their strapline, "It's
an awesome day to fly,"
kind of says it all.
These are very different brands
with very different styles.
So how do we create the
perfect persona for each brand?
First, we need to understand
the brand dimensions.
We'll interview stakeholders,
people from marketing, brand,
and customer experience.
We'll want to review the
brand book and any advertising
materials, print, TV,
radio, online, outdoor.
And we'll need to
experience the product.
In this case, take a trip.
We're distilling the
essence of the brand
into a few attributes.
In the case of
Important Airlines,
they're solid, confident,
expert, reliable,
straightforward, and safe.
You know just what you're
getting-- no surprises.
On the other hand,
Millennial is very different.
They focus on being bold,
hip, fun, youthful, friendly,
exciting, and delightful.
Next, we want to know everything
we can about the passengers.
Who are they?
What are their
expectations, et cetera?
We'll want to understand
the customer demographics,
the intended target segments,
and their frequency of use.
In the case of
Important, they're
catering to business
travelers, mid-30s and up,
high value, frequent flyers.
Once again, the Millennial
customer is very different.
They're holiday makers or young
families in their late teens
to mid-30s who are
budget conscious
and who, for the most
part, fly infrequently.
Now we want to determine the
tasks our persona will perform.
In this case, we're providing
flight status and information.
Is my flight on time?
Has it been delayed?
When is it expected?
Here's the fun part.
We're going to write biographies
for imaginary characters who
might be a good fit.
Often, we'll make the register
different between them.
One character might have a
more dominant personality
versus a character
that's more subservient.
First up is Important Airlines.
We mention register as
one of the attributes
we can discern from the voice.
Register is the social
standing of the persona
in relation to the listener.
So is the persona going to
be someone very familiar
like a peer?
Will it be an employee, perhaps?
Or will it be my
superior, something
like a mentor or advisor?
It's all about what will be
most appropriate for the brand
and task at hand.
For Important, we
wanted our personas
to be more of a butler.
So that's exactly
what we designed.
Meet Terrence Butler.
He's 56 years old, solidly
built, and comes from just
outside London.
The age indicates experience.
His size determines
how big-- and perhaps,
how deep-- his voice will sound.
We want to know
what influenced him,
so we make his parents a
hotel manager and a nurse.
Terrence knows hospitality
and how to provide help.
Now let's flashback to
the brand attributes
of Important Airlines--
solid, confident, expert,
reliable, straightforward,
safe.
You'll notice that a summary
of some of his biographical FAQ
shows how his persona
ties directly to the brand
attributes.
His very occupation implies
professional confidence.
He's been working for the
same family for 30 years,
indicating reliability
and expertise.
All-in-all, Terrence is a solid
fit for the Important brand.
Now we create some content
for the character to say.
We write a monologue
and some samples
dialogues to record with
proposed voice artists
if we're using
custom-recorded human speech.
If instead we're
using text-to-speech
we produce the monologue using
a selected text-to-speech voice.
These recordings
provide the writers
with a strong sense of
who they're writing for
and gives the voice
actor a powerful tool
to help her or him
get into character.
The monologue can be a paragraph
or two of the persona telling
a story to a friend.
It can be about anything at
all, something that happened
at work, a hobby, anything.
It helps to set
the tone of voice.
So here's Terrence Butler's
monologue about being a butler.
TERRENCE BUTLER: I quite
enjoy this occupation.
It's extremely gratifying to
know that one is indispensable.
If sir is stepping
out of an evening,
I shall have prepared sir's
dinner jacket and accessories.
And I shall, of course, assist
him in tying his bow tie.
The work of a gentleman's
gentleman is never done.
WALLY BRILL: You get
quite a good sense
of who he is, don't you think?
Although he's rendered
in text-to-speech voice,
his persona is solid
and well-represented.
Now here's an example of this
persona in an interaction.
It's called a sample dialogue.
And basically, it's
a script, like a play
with two characters, a
user and the persona.
Have a listen.
OK, Google, talk to
Important Airlines.
GOOGLE: Getting
TERRENCE BUTLER: Good morning.
You are through to
Important Airlines.
Am I speaking with Wally?
WALLY BRILL: That's right.
TERRENCE BUTLER: Thank you.
And do you require information
regarding your flight to London
today?
WALLY BRILL: Yes.
Notice his language, "Do
you require information
regarding your flight?"--
very formal.
Now let's shift over
to Millennial Airlines.
Remember their brand attributes,
bold, hip, fun, friendly,
exciting, delightful?
So what kind of
person would they
hire to serve their passengers?
Meet Helen Haighwater,
a 26-year-old gate
agent at San Francisco
International Airport.
Helen is super hip and stylish.
She shares a three-bedroom
flat in San Francisco
with a software developer
and a med student.
She's single but
currently dating Gary,
the drummer for a band
called the Ironic Three.
They're ironic, because
there are four members.
Helen studied drama and English
at school with a goal in mind.
Her dream is to be
a stand-up comic.
Her attention to detail comes
from her dad, a bank manager.
And her love of language
comes from her mother,
an English teacher.
And here's how we tie her
back to those brand values.
Now here's her monologue
rendered in text-to-speech.
HELEN HAIGHWATER:
I use everything.
And believe me, when you
deal with the passengers,
there's endless
amounts of material,
like the woman who
was going to Boston,
but her luggage was on its
way to Austin or the parents
off on holiday who each
expected the other one to bring
the kids to the airport.
Then there's the guy who
thinks he deserves an upgrade,
because he was in some obscure
rock band from 20 years ago
or something.
Let me tell you.
It's great training
for a stand up.
And I get paid for it.
And if I can deal
with them, there
isn't a heckler in the
world who can bother me.
WALLY BRILL: And here's
the sample dialogue.
OK, Google, talk to
Millennial Airlines.
GOOGLE: Getting
HELEN HAIGHWATER:
Millennial Airlines.
It's an awesome day to fly.
Is this Wally?
WALLY BRILL: Yup.
HELEN HAIGHWATER: Great.
Do you want info about your
flight to London today?
WALLY BRILL: That's right.
Notice how she says,
"do you want info?"--
very similar content but
very different language.
So that's it.
As you can see, persona
makes a huge difference
to the perception of the brand.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]